because if somebody does work on  themselves and those issues that you're  talking about and obviously he is you  know it always could come back together  again it could you know if both parties  are in the same place  three years from now right do you see  anybody else in those three years  what do you think  yeah were you talking  dare you asked me so you did you was  turning red i don't you're red like  you embarrassed was it fun how dare you  ask me a question if those three i know  there's three years fun i have fun no  matter where i am  what i'm doing yeah yeah i'm a  fun-loving person yeah yeah wow  [Laughter]  next question  i want to go to cebu i've always wanted  to go there we're going back in  september you are and you're broken up  yeah